okay for people joining this live stream
we are continuing to look at new
features for version 12.3 under
development
and we're looking at some visualization
features we already looked at a bunch of
these
and we are uh
looking at the last two on this list so
which should we look at first roger
uh access object is the one that's
actually intended to get you know
be experimental in 12.3 exactly
yeah categorical save that for last it's
more open-ended a little bit more
open-ended discussion
okay all right
access objects okay
so should i just look at the
documentation page for example it's a
good place to start
particularly tools was working
great oh that might have been from a
different
oh come on
what's happening here
can you look at the format menu just to
see if it
has loaded docutools or
there's something really weird going on
it's not loaded is it no it doesn't look
like i mean there should be a whole
bunch of new menu options or menu items
there
oh come on did it
cool somehow blow away its preferences
of where your
cvs directory is
well here hold on let me just
what is this doing
so this is trying to manually get this
version so
i can i can um okay let me just
pull it into here
okay so this is just i just opened it an
earlier version
okay axis object
so the fundamental concept is that an
axis object is like a line
it's just a graph experimentative
and um i guess the zeroth question is is
is a axis object the right name for it
and um it's not a bad name
okay so let's start off understanding
what an axis
is
you're saying an axis goes from point
one to point two so to speak
i mean not necessarily
i mean so so we have both finite and
infinite forms of axes
okay we could have a circular axis which
just goes around
we could have a circular one um but like
that one that you were looking at with
the point one and the point two you were
actually on the infinite axis one and so
i mean the points in that case are just
the specification of where it should be
and then it would actually draw until it
hit the plot range you know the edges of
the
you know the graphic yeah i get it
okay so in that case you do have a
direction
um right you have a
family okay so what is the design
what you're proposing here so the design
has three parts um
the first part is a specification
on sort of where the base curve is being
drawn
you know what the line is down the road
what the arc is
what circle etc okay
the second part of the design or the
second argument
deals with how do we
connect a scale to that
so the point zero zero should have the
value five and the point one one should
have the value
10 or whatever
and then everything after that is
currently designed as
options okay uh with
the options coming in
basically lists that form
a collection so so so
what you've got to give is
you know axis object has a path
and it has its essentially anchor points
which say this point
gets this value
correct right
okay
and so that gives you you know the curve
and this
and the scale
now in general this can be omitted
because it's deduced
automatically from the actual range of
the plot
well i mean it's it can be omitted in a
lot of cases because there's
sort of natural defaults you know if i
have a vertical axis
you know the you know there's an obvious
case where my vertical axis
is just the scale is just whatever the
coordinate system of the graphic is
i know yeah i know right if you have an
axis that
is going you know off at an angle
then there's not a natural one
i understand yep so the path
so often that mapping is defined by
yeah so i mean okay if the path
is horizontal
valve one is the x-coordinate
right naturally that will be the default
right
if the path is vertical it's the
y-coordinate but now in general
i mean honestly the the um
i see otherwise it's a function
well you're saying you can just define
it from two values
we just i mean usually we define it for
two values and then
you can interpolate between them
okay i mean that's the simplification
but it's probably okay
i mean i i can imagine that there are
you know that eventually there will be
cases where
it isn't you know a straightforward
interpolation
um right but that's diminishing returns
to some extent
oh yeah okay okay so let's let's now
look at the path
to begin with okay the other common case
is that you have multiple
x or y axis in which case obviously you
can't
derive them from the graphics i
understand that's the point
okay now the way access object would
work how do you say where in the picture
the axis
oh i see the pt1
if you're going to do this okay if
you're going to say frame
ticks goes to axis object
then that defines which then that
effectively defines the path
right that effectively defines it
positionally
yeah but it defines the path so what's
the first argument in that case
i would suggest either automatic or
omitted
and i haven't i i i don't have a
strong opinion on that at the moment
well i mean we need to have an argument
structure where it can be omitted
right
okay
so okay so that's the case where it is
auto positioned
um the case where it's in the graphic
and you just say it's a horizontal scale
oh i see that's crazy
i mean sorry yeah okay whatever
um
okay so what if that first
path thing how do we specify infinite
lines
uh simplest cases a pair of points there
are two ways to do it
is it just two oh yeah
well that's magnificent i mean in a
sense this
is just axis object i mean what i would
suggest
is you literally just do it because
you've got this pair of points
now it's a little bit of a shame
right i mean all this stuff through y
zero et cetera et cetera et cetera
just skip it all just say the first
argument
is a directive
there's a one-dimensional directive it
can be an arc it can be a this it can be
that you're not dealing with all these
weird
you know string names i mean there's a
limited grammar
of possible directives so in this case
you're
just doing you know x
okay but the difficulty with this
in a sense then the natural thing to
specify
here would be you know val one val two
for the two fiducial points so to speak
i'm making sense right yes
okay and in the in my
design the one that's in the notebook
right now yep
that is one of the forms that that
argument would take
you know for something like infinite
line okay
um i don't like that i don't like your
your whole reason i
i know you don't okay
i think it's a bad idea
i think it's not scalable i think it's
hard to understand and i think it's
arbitrary
but that may be but it also means
that there's
you know in some ways there's a little
bit less leeway for things to go wrong
yeah but look look look my point of view
is
the 90 percent case is going to be
people putting it into frame text and so
on
right sure
okay and so if it's a double axis it
will be
you know there'll have to be a syntax
for axis object axis object
and what it does if there are two axis
objects allocated to the same
frame element do you see what i'm saying
i see what you're saying i'm not
a hundred percent sure that i agree that
in a multi-axis thing
that they're all considered frame axes
or
what else are they they could just be
axes
well they could be axes sure and you
could put them which is not part of a
frame
i understand i understand so you know
what we've got
right now is axes arrow
and then we can just say okay so so in
the case of axes arrow
which i think right now is just true or
false right
and we've also got axis origin right
right you're not forgetting about those
things you're not trying to do one of
these
we're going to redo it and ignore
everything that's there before are you
you you haven't i i'm not ignoring
everything that has come before
so then don't right your system has to
interoperate with things like axis
origin
sure
i mean but it's starting out as a
primitive type thing
i'm a web but that's being used by
things that
you know the axis origin won't be you
know an issue for those
i'm well aware yeah look here's what i
think in terms of the matter design of
this
okay i think point one
don't hack this design because most of
the time
these are going to be auto generated
anyway so i'm saying
don't hack that design have this be a
nice clean thing which we can generalize
etc etc etc
and then figure out
you know and it maybe doesn't happen
instantly you know how these things get
consumerized
as you know for example frame ticks and
so on
and to my mind the way this should work
axes instead of just being true or false
right should be and serious true it can
say access object to blah blah blah
which is kind of equivalent to just
throwing the axis object
but if you're doing a plot it's not
equivalent if you're doing a plot they
would have to be some kind of epilogue
which is horrible
see what i'm saying right
we don't want them in an epilogue no no
no they won't be in an epilogue
you know if when we support axes goes to
axis object
it will not be a primitive thing it will
be
you know as if you know like the current
axes
i'm sorry what do you say oh you mean
axes yes in a plot you'll be able to say
plot
sine x axis goes to axis object
or whatever
and it will be similar as if you had you
know specified you know
ticks goes to you know
whatever the equivalent thing okay so my
suggestion here
is that i think i should save this file
somewhere
um
i think there's a copy of it there from
two days ago
so okay well all right so so listen i
think what we should do for axes
right i think that
axis arrow single axis object
should refer to the y-axis
do you see what i'm saying
and should you refer to both no no no no
no
no no no no no no it can't refer to both
you you've got a single vertical or
horizontal thing and that
that axis object is defined as being a
vertical axis object in that case
if you want to specify both the x-axis
and the y-axis why not do this
because that's different from how axis
is true and axis false work right now
what do you mean axis true and false
just switch on and off both axes right
yes okay so this is doing it one by one
i mean if we say i mean
that one doesn't bother me but you have
the list
i mean you can do x's goes to x and y
controlled separately right now
how my my concern is how how
how what axes do
plot with axes goes to true false oh
okay hold on oh
i see i see i see
okay fair point that point you have a
point there
okay it gets even crazier with like
parallel hexis plots
yeah all right okay so that's the thing
we haven't talked about yet
but but okay let's talk a little bit
about how
okay so presumably an axis object can
have a scaling function
which defines whether it's a logarithmic
scale or whatever
yep that's nice
okay and then
an access object can presumably have
text specifications right
correct whole little family of options
okay and an access object that
lives in a frame text
would by default put its feathers in one
particular direction right
yes
um don't you want to use
if you want axes to turn things on and
off shouldn't frame be the thing that
turn things on and off
for free yes maybe so
maybe so
well we need to talk about that i'm not
sure about that
right i mean you you could imagine that
going through either of them
yeah yes you can but i'm just for
consistency if you do one yeah no no i
agree
yeah we shouldn't mix and match right
okay
by the way that tick wrappers how to
format labels not a good name but a very
good concept
yeah i mean there's you know actually
probably
a couple of th that will probably
have to split into a couple of things on
because you have some tick labeling type
of operation
certific label modification
or styling formatting types of
operations
that you can do just on a single label
and there's some that you want to know
what all the labels are
up front to make a decision about how
the
uh formatting should happen okay
um so like you know as an example of
this that
is largely done automatically by the
front end right now
is how many zeros to put after
a one point depending on
you know is the smallest granularity 0.5
is it 0.25 etcetera and you know it
pads everything out to the same number
of things after the decimal place
right hold on a second um okay
hold on one second
okay sorry go ahead uh
okay what were you saying here so so i
want to raise a couple of things here so
these
these values here
they would normally be based on
the coordinates in the order in which
they appear
in the primitive here is that correct
yes okay
if the primitive
if the primitive is omitted
if there's a single coordinate if it's
if it's uh
aligned along a single coordinate
direction okay let me just understand
the cases and maybe you've already
dealt with the cases you'd say axis
object
of let's say x goes to vowel one
x one goes to vowel one
x two goes to val two
oops that will be the case for something
which is an x
position to access object correct
correct
[Music]
um
now i could imagine but i don't think
that makes any sense because it's not
auto
well actually i can imagine this i mean
this is this is an obvious thing to do
this is a way this would be a
specification of a line that goes from
x1 y1
to i mean that's the obvious thing to do
in that case
right yep the question is is it a finite
line or is an infinite one
and that by default i think okay
maybe
um
i mean i think it probably is infinite i
mean i'm just
okay all right so
i'm just trying to avoid the case we
have to repeat the coordinates here and
the vowel one vowel two
but that's okay so so
in the order that the coordinates appear
here so
they will appear here okay so that
specifies the values
now the plumage so one thing that is
different from the text specification
is the orientation of the text right
right so this design essentially
transposes the traditional tick spec
and names the heck out of it
yeah well the traditional tech spec is
is incomprehensible
right um hopefully this is more
comprehensible
um and so what these options
do is i mean
you can either give them a value or you
can give them a list of values
if you give them a list of values
then you're sort of looking at the first
element
in the list across all the options
defines a collection
of ticks with you know a
you know similar style orientation
labeling
etc the second set of items in the list
defines a second
collection of ticks
so on so forth
i'm sorry you're saying in the current i
mean in your model here
there is a single family okay so you're
breaking apart tick positions
right so scroll down to the
bottom of the notebook why aren't you
giving something bro there's an
association that can have
every for every tick can just say
i mean you know that the at the bottom
level it's just a list of associations
that say
position arrow blah you know
style arrow blah
blah blah blah blah for every single
tick
so you can you know so you can generate
them in the program
can you type out a simple version of
that so i can
or start to do it so i can understand
exactly what you're proposing
i'm proposing this is the position of
the tick
1.5 the label
is i don't know let's say that the
position of the tick is
n of pi over 2 the label
is traditional form
you know pi over two the style
is you know text
the
actually not even think i you know the
style is text 11 point
the um orientation
is whatever it is etc that's what i'm
proposing
i think there's actually a pretty decent
idea that this is the ultimate
lowest level that is the ultimate lowest
level
and
it's fine i think it's fine for
something that
you're generating programmatically
but i don't think it's something that
you would want to
input as no because for every single
tick
right every single tick right but the
way we can think about these other
things
is they are generators of a list of
these associations
and that's how we think about them
[Music]
and okay so let's take a look now
wow the position of the label relative
um you know so this might say placed
blah blah blah blah blah
or it might have an alternative thing
that says you know label offset blah
blah blah
okay
wait a minute what's place what does
this have to do with another thing
um for that is for axis label
okay well this documentation should be
in the under access level presumably
um there's two notes above it is
where it introduces access label um
no no i meant under as in as in on the
page for access label
well yeah so i mean access label
for the axis option axes option does not
currently support these
when it does it will be documented there
so this is labeling for the axis object
as opposed to for the plot right now
correct
okay so what you're saying is so what
i'm saying
is there's a list of ticks and they get
specifications like this
the access as a whole also has a whole
bunch of specifications
whatever it is am i making sense
um
now okay so you've got a whole forest of
options here as well
okay which of these are already
options for something
nice um
let's see we have
currently
access labeled no because this one has
it has a singular i mean we could switch
it to
axes label and henry is the existing
graphics
you know option name
um perhaps not yeah okay
yeah i mean it's a question of a base
style is not how to style the axis
that's wrong
base styles are for you know that really
is a base style it's not how to style
the axis
that's a completely separate thing how
to style the axis
do you what i'm saying what do you mean
base style is for the ticks
isn't it no no it's for the whole thing
base style is any primitive which is
directly represented in the front end
and has options
has a base style
or any box i should say but it's a real
mess to say the line is green
that's not where you want to put you
know base style arrow green
is not what you would want to make clean
is it
we we we could choose or not to reflect
base style here
but uh you'll get base style whether you
want it or not
oh i understand that i understand that
the base style would usually be a line
box
style and weird stuff like that right
that's not what these guys want here
they want something which is basically
just an access style
right which we don't have right now oh
yes we do
actually still what is axe's style yeah
yeah
yeah plot red i mean base style
and axey style interplay with one
another it's
in the cr in the current prototype
it works what is base what's that it
works very well
what is base style isn't doesn't it have
to say line box
options goes to whatever to get it to
work uh
it so base style if passed directly to
the box
or a box generating function applies
directly to it so it will you know if if
passed to a line box
it would be the line box options version
if passed to a grid box it will be the
grid box options version
right i mean steven do graphics of disk
and base style goes to red
okay and what happens if i say base
style our
section
so if you had any text in there
it would be section styled
assuming that uh the the text box
doesn't have its own overwriting style i
don't
think it does but yeah okay
now now the interesting thing about
graphics is that graphics has a number
of these
sub you know base style is the big one
but it has sub selector styles which can
override the base style for
pieces so axis style is one label style
is another
and there are more i don't remember what
the whole zoo of them is
okay text style frantic style
maybe that's it i think there's one i'm
missing
yeah so graphics box and graphics 3d box
are a bit unusual
in having this zoo of styles most
most boxes only have base style or maybe
you know one other style associated with
it
yeah so you could also add label style
goes to red and then you would get
that font and that font size and
actually does label style apply to text
by default i don't remember i'm
i'm pretty sure it does okay
okay
right so most of the stuff before tick
labels
has very close analogs in the existing
system
i guess rotate tick labels is new
but
um
rotate labels
label this is a bit of a mess
let's decide what we would like these
names to be
and then let's decide how you know they
map onto the names that we invented 30
years ago
35 years ago
um
okay
so what do we need to okay so we've got
which text to include
right
we've got styling of each tick
your family of tech or type of tech
we've got um
styling of axis
and we've got labeling
oh gosh which text to include styling of
okay
labeling of ticks
labeling of access
right yep okay
is that it actually
right some reason it didn't make it we
need sort of two labels for axes
right um
so for instance units and scales
if we use that and the user uses that
it cannot be survived
well in particular the axis labels okay
so
so
labeling of axes okay both uh
what the axis represents
and multiplier
scales because the axis could be in
thousands for example
exactly or meters or right
or thousands of meters multiply
units is what i mean
right so this this would be you know
goat population
and that would be thousands per acre or
something
right unlikely well yeah
um
okay all right
now another question here is
like the sizing of ticks
how thick they are etc and and do they
scale with the
image size or do they stay fixed like
a font can scale or stay fixed right
yep so do you have those
those kinds of controls yep
okay all right
default major minor where are the
defaults being set
they are the global defaults
right i mean what's on the style sheet
or what
i don't think it's controlled by the
style sheet i mean i think it's just
hard-coded in the front end
um
which i mean having you know i mean
exposing control for that
is maybe interesting but um
i i don't know that it's immediately you
know necessary
um you know it's major and minor you
know that we've
been looking at you know for the past 30
years or whatever um
okay all right so well
do you think you have a scheme here for
all of this stuff
here's approximately end ticks multiples
of dx
okay well that's the same as the text
the things that we have in text isn't it
what do you mean the text
the current text option has the same
kind of choices does it not
no no okay the current ticks option
is like automatic none or
you tell you give a list of where things
are
possibly with how they're labeled and
styled and
yeah right okay
so one possibility i mean this isn't
this is
i mean we prototyped this long time ago
and it's been in use for some time where
we generate
and eject the primitives
yeah okay i understand so look my
suggestion would be this
very very long form could actually be
the new right hand side for the text
option
because i'm saying you could use the
legacy one but we'd also document
primarily document this form where
you're just saying this is what i want
these are all the ticks i want
boom here it is you see what i'm saying
that's the full control and everything
else is overridden by
a full text specification like that
that makes sense right okay
so this is for
you mean at the graphics level when if
you want to it's like an extended
version of existing ticks at the
graphics at the global graphics level
yeah
yeah okay which is not axis
well no no no no no i meant this either
inside an access object or if you wanted
to at the global graphics level
okay
okay first people are asking about two
axis plots and other things
the whole point here is you can have an
axis that is any
shape you can have a spiral axis you can
have a circular axis you can have an
axis of 45 degrees
you can have an axis wherever you want
it and that's relevant
what are what are plots that have axes
at funny well i mean they're nomograms
to begin with but they're also what has
an axis of 45 degrees
something where i mean you could imagine
like parametric plot it would be nice to
label
the curve as an axis
for the curve case go go to the end of
the notebook because there's
an example there that there's a couple
of
nice examples at the very end yeah those
two
that are pink boxing right now that's
sad um
right so that one is you know
constructing a ternary
list plots um using you know varicent
trig
coordinates basically something
we should probably have as a built-in
function but i know we have a bunch of
prototypes
we're coming to it okay
so in this case you've got three
separate axis objects here
right what are you doing about
collisions
in that case nothing automatically right
now
um and the
i think you do need a collision
avoidance thing
it's in the pipeline we it's under
it's under development okay yeah
um and the i wonder why
in this case the tick labels are
supposed to be on the other side of the
axis
so what um okay so
but but the yeah yeah there's something
wrong with
what steven's seeing here because the
the tick labels aren't even in the right
direction
okay so i've got the wrong version
somehow
okay
so you're proposing here with tick
positions what does this mean is this
major minor ticks or what yep
those are major and minor text specs
okay yeah so from minus five to five and
steps of one
from minus five to five in steps of
point two
you know another thing we could do in
the case where
i'm thinking here
in in the case
where you're not giving explicit access
object when you're when you're in a plot
we could have something where
somehow you know
the default i'm just trying to figure
out how we get
all of these tick position options and
things
for the x-axis and for the y-axis
separately specified
you get what i'm saying because i think
this thing about combining them is very
confusing
okay did you understand what i'm saying
uh
maybe i mean i'm sort of imagining that
we're approaching our
third design for the specification for
the frame
set of options you know because
because originally you know up you know
prior to version six
it took just a flat list what went
around the edges in some particular
order
like bottom left top right though and
then we switched to
a two by two matrix of specifications
that were
left right and bottom top right so what
i'm suggesting is that we enhance that
we add to that the possibility of an
association
because left goes to whatever right goes
to whatever
yeah simple as that that's a simple
thing it just would save me having to
look up in the documentation
every time which order it goes in
i think that's a simple thing which i
think we should support
um
okay right and we've i mean we actually
do that a little bit
in i mean so for parallel axis plot
which we
introduced in 12.2
uh last year yeah
yeah there's you know 20 i mean maybe
not 20. but seven axes or whatever
and so it allows accident you know axis
goes to
a list of two goes to you know whatever
your spec is
to one fine so we've already got exits
okay that's good that's what we should
do for this
okay okay let's just go through the rest
of this
oh boy let's look at the options for a
moment and just
you know run through them real quick and
you know
get feedback on names and general
concepts
i mean i wish this could be called tick
label rotation
because i think this is or tick label
orientation
instead of rotate tick labels yeah to
get
all the things together
well yes but also okay
because i think it's not it's not a
question of do you rotate them or not
right what is the case where you're
rotating them
oh i see it's when when the thing is a
vertical axis
yeah i just did that actually recently i
just had rotated ones recently because
they were going to collide with each
other
okay fine an orientation is better
because so orientation arrow automatic
would be
well orientation none would be just
rectilinear you know the thing is
regular horizontal red text
right so okay non automatic would be
uh have them sort of uh be
the outer orientation so if it's a
vertical axis they read
down the axis presumably
right
okay i mean they they are horizontal
text you read them like no you don't
twist your head
i mean you don't lean your head over yes
they are that no no no no no no no
that's not right that's what
tic the tick label rotation means you do
turn your head
right just like axis rotate labels
rotate label for axes again you turn
your head
the words read down
do you see what i'm saying
right if you have rotate label on a plot
with a frame
and frame labels then
which frame label is it on the side
um
just a random word of four
we'll hit all of them is that right it
will just work with four like that it
doesn't have to be
two sub lists no it should work for
backward compatibility purposes
wherever that message is coming from who
knows but but there you see the
the um okay
so that's what it does roger but but
that's not tick labels
no i know because we don't have tick
labels here look do you want to see an
example of tick labels that were rotated
yeah for the horizontal axis it makes
perfect sense because they run into each
other
for the vertical automatic it's it makes
a lot of sense to not rotate them
if it's an automatic setting yes fair
enough i agree with you
i mean like like for example here's we
could very well rotate them like true or
something
that that's that's very good i know so
that's an example of rotated horizontal
text
right right
okay so so
so what does automatic mean then does
automatic mean
rotate them if need be to to make them
fit
does it mean something else i mean i i
think we leave automatic
you know a little bit flexible right now
um well automatic but
maybe we don't even have automatic for
right now
i mean if you scroll down i have a table
of settings for the rotate things
um i mean we even explored other outer
layouts which is like have three lanes
of
of of labels um
you know two or three lanes of tick
labels
and then you know every third label
goes in the same lane every third tick
label goes in the same lane but that's
why we should have this specification
right because in the end you're just
going to generate the whole thing
programmatically like this
because the program is not going to be
that ugly that generates all of this
stuff
you can have mod you know whatever it is
here in the orientation
so i'm saying yeah i mean what i was
talking about now wasn't even
orientation it's it's translation
okay
um what about the thickness of the ticks
do you have a text style option
text style okay
right this is okay fine but anyways so
if we go back to
the options yeah okay so we have
i'm just going to go through them real
quick you know axis label is a
label for the overall
axis object yep uh supports placed it
allows you to put it at one end or the
other
somewhere along this middle etc
base style controls the style of the
x object it's going to
like it controls everything if you say
orange both the axis
from the base curve to the tick labels
is orange
yep um label style applies to the sets
of labels
okay i think there should be a separate
axis style
okay to control just the curve or you
want the base style behavior renamed to
access stock no no i think to control
just the curve
okay now that's
super confusing with axes style that we
have right now
right and question
would tick style inherit for max's style
if on set it yes so if i specify
axis style orange and i don't specify a
text style are the tix orange
do we have a text style right now yes
oh that's right yeah
which right now inherits from axes style
yes
well i mean i think that's probably the
right thing to do but
it's yeah i think it is the right thing
to do but i think also
other than the fact that axey's style is
a little bit confusing
it's probably the right name here
well okay let's imagine there's an
access style
that right now is not axes style
do you get what i'm saying
and it's introduced experimentally for
this
okay okay rotate label i understand it's
kind of a gross
name for this i mean it would be axis
label orientation
would be the correct thing
right
but you know rotate label is a nice
short name
which we've been using for 35 years or
something
34 years uh
god that's a long time anyway for one of
these
anyway um
okay target units i understand that
for this individual axis and
okay it's just you know how to deal with
scales and positioning stuff and
all that good things wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute you've got the
multiplier at the end
times 10 to the 17 or something and then
you've got times 10 to the 17 in meters
per second
and then you've got the other what does
target units do it it converts
to but let's say i gave target units
and i gave a multiplier like a thousand
i didn't just give a pure
uh unit unitary unit so to speak
would it then go times ten to the seven
you know times times a thousand it
should do that that's what we should do
in other words if target unit went
target units went to a million ten to
the sixth let's say
then it would uh label the axis
in multiples of ten to the sixth
do you see what i'm saying i i see what
you're saying um
i don't think i mean it's a new feature
for
target units i know that but yeah
um so i haven't thought through that
particular
path yet okay but i think that's a
worthwhile thing i've wanted to do that
much recently
because we've been down this path a few
times we haven't yet designed it in
yes okay um a thousand whatever
and i i think it just you know
factors it out and yeah and if it's a
pure number then the formatting by
default will be
you know thousands s or maybe times a
thousand or something
probably the probably the more more sort
of internationalizable version of it
would be times a thousand
small and gray i think
um here's a question i want only integer
unit okay so the two issues one is with
stupid decimal points in units
and the other was with integer units
only how do i do that
never use a non-integer so that would be
tick positions goes to a spec involving
you know brace one brace
you say that you want your ticks as
multiples of one
well i think we might want something
that says integers here
sure as well we can translate things
like that easily enough
okay
but if you had two there there would be
in multiple so two
absolutely
what are we going to do about the
trailing points decimal points
seven point seven point five et cetera
that's a that's a number form formatting
thing but that's an important default
that has to be all right right um
and right now it should be handling that
pretty much correctly okay fine you know
integers if it if able and
you know pad out to a constant number of
places after the decimal place
right you know so 1.0 for 1.5 and
1.00 there's also 1.25
wait a minute why isn't just one 1.5
why isn't it that it should be that that
looks really weird
yeah it looks weird i don't think it
looks weird if it's 1 1.5
2.5 etc i don't think that looks weird
i mean that's what i've done any reason
you didn't say that 30 years ago then
yeah because i didn't think we had as
many um because it's
because what we're doing now is exactly
what press describing and have been
doing forever
i mean you can see it on the frame edge
at the bottom of your other notebook
well that looks pretty reasonable
maybe it does doesn't it
but maybe it's breaking in some
particular case
why do you think it's breaking in some
particular case i mean i have seen
sporadic cases where it didn't do that
but i mean with the exception of
probability scale plots okay all right
okay okay i i need to get to another
meeting so
let's keep going here okay we've got
tick label
sides which somehow reminds me of sort
of side orders of french fries and
things
[Laughter]
right so so we have tick label sides and
we have tick sides
and what the heck is that what
sorry access to place ticks
what okay tick
label sides
okay what side of the access to place
the ticks i understand that
which one is tick what
that's the tick oh i see whether you
want the ticks
the tick labels sort of
perched on the axe on the tick or
you know beneath the tick
don't you usually have them beneath the
tick
it depends i mean so like the frame
you know the tick the ticks are you know
on the right on the left side and on the
left on the right side
oh gosh yes and
um yeah but really what you want to say
is is the tick label
being skewered or not
you don't want to say is it literally to
the left or right i think you want to
say
because those are the stylistic
differences is it being is it perched on
the tick or or not
i'm gonna have to to leave
okay so do i but but okay
um i'm just gonna say i agree this is
for me has been one of the most
confusing things
you know especially when you if you
specify an axis
upside down then everything flips around
right i think that what this is in terms
of okay so what is this this is
um
okay so this is basically a tick label
position
and really it's it's sort of a below
above
below above or it's inward outward
see the problem is top above below i
mean it depends are you horizontally
vertically flipped over et cetera et
cetera et cetera
right which is why i use left and right
because i can at least
you know imagine an ant walking along my
axis incomprehensible
in my opinion i i suppose
um okay i i understand that there's the
concept of a
okay hold on well that that's a
different okay
first if you're a physicist this should
be i understand
left-hand rule right hand rule i
understand that
now i agree with you that
i mean maybe it's clockwise and
anti-clockwise counterclockwise
is that comprehensible absolutely i find
that
being more incomprehensible
okay so in the direction of the scale
well what's true here this one is right
hand
and this one is left hand right
look one possibility is inward
outward those are names which mean
the ticks are going to the innards of
the plot and to the outers of the plot
so to speak
and that's this case is they're both
inward
right okay but now if you what is the
line on the diagonal mean
it's picks it random okay because that's
not going to be defined
that's what it was doing earlier this
week
i was resizing a graphic and it was
flipping back and forth
okay in any case so you know the
alternative would be left right
which would me which would have your
meaning
i can also imagine you know inward
outward is also to the positive
direction and to the negative direction
right there's also similar to those
is positive negative
and i can imagine it being useful to
specify these separately
because i can imagine you want always to
the positive direction
even as your plot you know as you change
your plots to be a plot where the axis
runs the other way
so that it flips from one side to the
other as it turns itself around
that's correct
so inward would always mean pointing
towards the center look
i think inward means um
uh towards scale 0.5.5 that's what i
think yes
towards center
i would mean diverging from the center
and now you know if you have a a spiral
axis i don't know what you do
you can pick and some some criterion oh
better what about a spiral axes in a 3d
space
well at any given local point as a
center but i agree that gets really
complicated
now in a 3d situation does the left
right mean anything
i mean my plan for this for 3d
is that it's determined by
you know sort of your viewpoint how
you're looking at it so it's billboarded
in some way
exactly you know that you don't want to
have an acne
ticks and tick labels that
the line is cutting through and
obscuring your ability to read it yeah
okay fine all right okay so this is
this is an idea about
tick label position
that's tick no no i'm sorry that's tick
position what we just talked about is
tick position
no no tick orientation
yes
i'm gonna have everything being
orientation
okay so then
well there's tick label orientation
which is yet separate and by the way
with this orientation thing we probably
should have the same inward outward type
options for all of these orientation
things what we were previously calling
rotation
why not allow the possibility of inward
outward and so on as options
and left right and so on as options
because they all mean that you can do
that for an access as
oh well i think it's
i'm not sure i'm following that okay so
so
access label where is it
no that doesn't make sense never mind
it's okay that's a different thing it
can be done with placed
yep um
but like rotating the tick labels yeah
from
horizontal to vertical or whatever by
the way does plot label work with placed
at this point
no it needs to
okay does that make sense
no no no not me okay i've noted it in
miscellaneous
who does it go to um i i brought that up
you know a few months ago um as a wish
list item
and uh scared
senior front end developers well
okay we need plot label goes to place
not only that we need plot label
we need some mechanism to have multiple
plot labels placed in different places
i guess i guess i always just assume
that's what labeled was for
but you can't have label without a point
what i look no no no no he means the v6
you know labeled of plot of
no i'm i'm talking about i want a label
right there inside the plot
okay i don't think you can do that with
labels
no okay so that's what i want i want
something where you can put
a label in an arbitrary scaled
coordinator or not scale coordinate in
the plot
just text without any
does any plot label go actually in the
plot i mean it's within the frame of the
plot but
it's not like it's inside the graph fair
enough right now you can do this with
epilogue right but that's really yucky
you can do it with legendary
do what with legend did what you were
just describing
how legend of plot
your text and whatever that position is
i didn't know that i thought it gave you
all kinds of weird you know
uh sort of action of distance legends
it does that too okay but
i don't think it does this by default
and what i'm saying is we need a way
to get random text attached to random
points
in the in the plot i mean
look it's really like a modernized
version of epilogue
okay separate discussion can we make
sure that's on the list for a separate
time
okay because i i really need to run to
another meeting
okay so
let's see um
so what we are still left with is
perched or unpurged
right
that can be done okay so i've got a
suggestion i've got a suggestion
okay face and tip
but that's what tick label position
could be at base or tip
or you know possibly some kind of number
that that is
as you've said along the the axis here
of these things you see what i'm saying
this is a tick label orientation which
we discussed
and now just take label orientation
follow tick orientation
by default it is opposite
okay um yes so if you have your
technical inside the label is on the
opposite
oh yeah but but that okay wait a minute
what's orientation versus rotation
orientation is what you had turned
rotation into
okay well then this isn't the right
thing this is
tick position i mean we've now got tick
positions right
so this would be tick positioning
somehow
and then we've got tick that's that's
tick label positioning and then there's
tick label orientation
which is the rotation option
right okay
i'm not thrilled about tick positions
versus tick positioning
um and we could rename one of them
location
i don't think it helps um don't we
already have a tick
we don't have a tick positions yet yeah
well the other possible thing will be
tick values
because that's what it is
i would be fine with that
take values and take positioning
or just throwing out their
tick placements as an alternative to
tick positioning
i don't like it i think placement is is
not
placement i think placement sounds more
like it's along the axis
rather than
well the other thing we could do is call
it tick rendering or something
i probably want to reserve that for
something else
alignment
totally crazy yeah it's viable
and somehow alignment makes more sense
for the labels than the ticks themselves
i
still think it's not terrible i mean
it's like your left aligned your right
alight
does that actually make sense in our
left right rule
no it's the opposite way around isn't it
if you're right aligned that means
you're
you're you're against a right hand
edge
um about just default would be above
and then you could have center and
invert which would put it on the
opposite side
well i could say inverted right that's
not a bad thing
i agree or reversed
inverted irreversed we've used reverse
and reversed elsewhere just generally in
the system
okay reversed
but that still doesn't give us a name
for this yeah
how about correction direction i was
just going to say that
telepathic communication
that's the obvious name take direction
yep inward outward
maybe center and then we can do
at some point down the road you know
allowing
ticks that aren't perpendicular to the
axis
right tick positions i think is better
than tick values i think tick values is
weird
okay
and tick labels is what again
it's the actual labels right is the
actual labels for
whether to auto label them or not
i see right you know for most of the
time it'll be auto label but it won't be
if it's multiples of pi for example it
won't be able to be auto labeled
you see what i'm saying right
i mean there's a certain argument
because that is such a common case
that we could have something like tick
label multipliers or something
we just say pi
um right
yeah no i was i mean the other thing i
was thinking is that for something
is that tick positions similar to how we
added integers we should add
you know a trig thing
yeah okay
is
it's not necessarily an integer multiple
of pi but you know could be a
half inch multiple of pi it's rational
multiples of pi small rational
i mean small denominator rational
multiples of pi
yeah but i suspect this will be useful
where that's explicitly given
let's see is that a base or what would
that be tick label
it's not really a multiplier it's a tick
label
factor yeah it's possibility
that's possible here's better than
multiplier
all right i think you've got a decent
design here
i think we've gone through essentially
everything is there anything else you
need to go through i'm really late
i if there is i'm not sure what it is at
this point
okay all right okay so this um who is
who is is it brady
you know where to get this notebook
right yes
okay i think we've had a few comments on
the live stream here let me just look at
n-dimensional axis objects
oh my gosh no there are n-dimensional
axis objects that emerge compositions of
lower dimensional disjoint axis objects
as long as the dependencies are
specified no we are not doing
three-dimensional we're not doing
specifying
a point no not yet
i mean it reminds me of hypergraphs and
things where you're specifying
um
yeah hyper axes yes you can have a hyper
axis
just like you can have a two-dimensional
slider or a circular slider for that
matter
um
okay this looks good okay right
try and get it implemented indeed
okay look forward to seeing more
okay anything else for here no i think
we're
all we're good okay terrific
okay told you also